[Applause]
you know
hi everybody I love that opening song
that was great well thank you for having
me here I'm Kirsten Tobi co-founder of
revolution foods one of the things that
we that we really thought about when we
first started was and and kind of what
drove us to start the company was you
know the fact that every kid in this
country deserves to have access to
high-quality healthy food no matter
where they grow up no matter the zip
code no matter where they come from no
matter where they go to school so so my
business partner Kristin seems obvious
right that access to healthy food is a
fundamental human right
so my visit part business partner
Kristen and I started 12 years ago now
we met 14 years ago here right up the
street at UC Berkeley and in Business
School and we kind of came together
around this idea that you know we could
create a new model for how kids have
access to to food and and kids and
families really we've always kind of
focused on where the greatest needs in
our communities and and you know when we
were looking at this when we were in
business school we saw you know all of
the statistics about the obesity
epidemic is on the rise type 2 diabetes
is impacting at this point in inner-city
communities it's impacting one and two
kids which is a shocking statistic and
you know we have kids at this point in
history slated to live a shorter life
span than their parents which is the
first time ever and that shouldn't
happen it's all because of preventable
preventable nutrition related diseases
and food-related diseases so we started
revolution foods to make what we call
kid inspired chef crafted food
accessible to all
well it won't spend a ton of time
talking about the sort of the origin
story but because they asked me today to
kind of focus on a lesson that I can
teach you guys so so I do have a little
a little lesson that I'll that'll kind
of dig into which is one of our newest
newest initiatives that we're working on
and kind of how we're approaching that
but we started here in Oakland actually
right down the street or was our first
school
a charter school called lighthouse
community charter school wonderful
school they just graduated their first
class of kids who have eaten revolution
foods now for twelve years and they're
now going to college which is exciting
so they've it's been exciting to kind of
grow with partners like that who have
you know charter schools who have been
growing alongside of us we've started
here in Oakland but we very quickly
expanded to new geographies we expanded
to Southern California to Texas to New
Orleans to Denver to DC to New Jersey
New York and most recently Boston so
we're now serving about two million
meals a week and in this next school
year it'll be even more than that
including breakfast lunch after school
meals after school supper after school
snacks in the summertime we serve summer
meals to kids who come to either city
sponsored or or other community
sponsored programs we work with Boys and
Girls Clubs YMCAs and other places
basically anywhere where kids are
spending time we offer meals to them and
we built the company with a real focus
on making sure the meals are accessible
so accessibility has been one of the one
of the really driving factors of of how
we've grown how we've how we've you know
really built the whole model and
accessibility to us means that kids need
to be able to have our food or have
access to our food and families need to
have access to our food regardless of
their income levels so we built the our
whole platform is built around the the
USDA sponsored national school lunch
program school breakfast program other
federally subsidized programs and about
eighty percent of the kids who eat our
meals each day qualify for free lunch at
school so that means they're coming from
families that are living at a hundred
and thirty percent of the poverty line
or below and that's been you know really
fundamental to to how we how we've
started and how we've continued to grow
and how we've been very focused in terms
of our mission and our vision so family
fresh fish family dinners is is what I'm
here to talk to you about so you might
think oh revolution foods that's a
school lunch company well school lunches
is how we started and is you know
probably three-quarters of our current
business we also do breakfast as I
mentioned
and we are really focused on you know
making sure that camel e's have access
to to good nutrition and and nutrition
education so one of the things that as
we've grown and as we've been serving
more and more communities we've had
teachers and principals and parents in
the schools that we work with say you
know it's great that you're feeding my
kid breakfast and lunch and sometimes a
snack or a meal after school but I'm
still struggling to get dinner on the
table and dinner is a real challenge and
you know as busy working parents you
know many of us who are who are you know
running the company are also struggling
to get a healthy dinner on the table
it's kind of like getting a getting a
healthy dinner on the table sort of
knows no boundaries in terms of
socioeconomic status and and all that
sort of thing so so we really so we saw
dinner as a way to to both increase the
impact that we are having in our
communities and to solve a real problem
that is that's kind of within our realm
of core competency but the way that
we've approached this I think is an
interesting and an interesting kind of
path and that's what I'm here to to kind
of walk you through so one of the things
we wanted to make sure to not do was to
sort of pivot and say okay well now
let's focus on something new and let's
get a whole team and let's invest a lot
of money we've really tried to to build
you know kind of a small kind of
innovation focused kind of skunkworks
approach to to what we're doing here but
to do it in a really thoughtful way and
to be very clear and methodical about
the about the process so the insight you
know that we had was you know we have
this opportunity we have these hunt you
know several hundred thousand families
that are reliant on our program that we
have a daily touch with because we're
serving their their kids in schools we
have you know at this point we have
several hundred refrigerated trucks on
the road every day we have culinary
centers where we're making and preparing
and delivering fresh meal fresh meals on
a daily basis we have this incredible
kind of infrastructure and capacity and
we said well how can we leverage that to
bring a dinner solution to families so
we kind of launched an innovation
process
and the very first thing that we did was
to talk to the end-user so this is you
know and when you're starting something
new whether you're starting a new
business whether you're starting you
know a new creating a new product within
your existing business talking to your
consumer it's probably the most
important thing that you can do and
don't just do this once you gotta keep
doing it you got to keep going back to
them figuring out if it if what you're
if what you're creating is working for
them maintaining an open mind so don't
go in you know we didn't go into this
thinking okay we know exactly what this
solution looks like and we know how
we're going to deliver it and we know
what it's gonna what the menu is going
to be and we we really kind of let the
process unfold as we worked with our
consumers and we tested a lot of
different things before we kind of honed
in on here's what the products to look
like here's what the solution needs to
look like and I'll say well we're still
on this journey we're not we're not kind
of done and I'll kind of tell you where
we are today with it
but listen prototype learning and
prototype again so you know try to be we
when we first started this which was
about a year ago we started doing the
kind of consumer work and talking to
talking to parents and teachers and and
kids and families and we went into
people's kitchens and cooked with them
we looked at you know what are people
eating what solutions are currently out
there what's the price point that a
family like a middle-income family has
to spend on a dinner and I can tell you
it's not the same price point that you
might be targeted with your you know the
postcards you're getting from milk it
company is about like only twelve
dollars per serving it's a lot less than
that what families actually have to -
who are you know families who are
struggling to make ends meet have to
spend on a dinner and then we built our
we built our kind of innovation team and
and this is a really important you know
the way that we've built this team is is
important because we've you know done
innovation before and I think done it
incorrectly but the way that we've that
we've done it in this in this case is we
have kind of taken people who are real
experts within our business so we have a
we have a team of fifteen hundred people
across the country and you know many of
those people are you know 99% of those
people are focused on delivering on our
core business and I should probably
emphasize as a part of this that you
know continuing to deliver on our
or business and grow our core business
which continues to which continues to
grow we continue to add new schools and
new cities that we didn't want to
distract that 99% of our team in in
building this innovation team but what
we did is we found you know a few people
within the company who who knew a lot
about either our supply chain our menu
development process our school
partnerships our marketing channels and
we brought them together and said let's
make this a team of people that will
kind of come into this innovation space
and work on this project but while still
you know doing your day job as a part of
the as a part of the core business and
as we kind of built the the product of
the proposition we started you know
realizing where we needed more dedicated
people to come in and and take on
specific parts of the process but but
really being thoughtful about how to
craft the team not kind of walling off a
bunch of people in a separate room and
saying you know go create something
completely different but instead you
know I was trying to think of what's the
right metaphor a lot of entrepreneurs
talk about you know you're building the
plane while you fight fly it or you're
building the ship while you sail it well
I think the best metaphor for this is
that we're we're building this train and
it's and I know it's kind of old-school
cuz nobody takes trains anymore but it's
a but I think the metaphor works because
we're building this train and as we've
grown the business you know the Train
continues going in the direction that
we're going we're continuing to like run
the core business to our goal but what
we're doing now is we're building a new
car that's going to be on the back of
the Train and that's eventually going to
you know be able to be you know we're
gonna build more of those cars but you
want the car to be connected to the rest
of the train and you want people to be
able to come and go and and to bring
what works on that current train and
bring it into the new car and develop it
but also spend time thinking about how
can we do something different so that
that kind of idea of pulling a
cross-functional team across you know
from the existing business but having
them focus on this new area is an
important an important piece so being
careful not to build that dedicated team
too fast I think you know bringing
people who are kind of industry experts
from you know other places and saying
okay we're going to build this new thing
so go off and build it is it's going to
take you in the wrong direction building
on your core assets is the way to
you know really kind of learn from
what's going on in the current business
and bring it into the new business and
then as the process unfolds always being
clear on what you know what you don't
know and what you're testing for so
we've done a lot of testing and learning
over the last nine to twelve months in
this in this space and we're always very
careful to say okay well we just did
this test we learned this this and this
but there's still a lot of things that
we don't know so we've tested you know
is it going to work better if families
can order this dinner platform ahead of
time or do they want to do they want to
buy it on impulse
so we've tested both you know both kind
of environments we've tested with a
smart fridge in a school site so that
it's you know parents can actually come
and pick up a meal when they pick up
their kids from school we've tested a
smart fridge in a more of a workplace
site because maybe parents want to bring
a dinner dinner meal home from their
workplace but always being careful to
know what you're testing and what you're
learning and and when you've learned it
then you start then you can start to
really kind of invest in and double down
on that learning product development so
we have as we embarked on this process
we went into we talked to a lot of
consumers as I mentioned we went into
people's kitchens we tested a lot of
different ideas and we looked at all the
different I mean the milk industry right
now is exploding there's so many
different ideas out there but what we
heard from from the consumers that we
talked to is that you know as busy
working parents people don't have time
to be you know learning how to cook and
spending 45 minutes of prep time while
they're trying to you know juggle family
juggle all the other competing
priorities of their time and then
cooking the dinner for another 45
minutes and then having a you know sink
full of dirty dishes we talked to people
who you know have looked at that or if
you have tried the current kits and
they're so tired of all the garbage and
the trash that comes every time you get
a box delivered to your doorstep
and then we talked about like what's the
price point that people need to have
this to truly be accessible to the
communities that we that we are serving
and so we've really honed in on a
product that is that meets all of those
that kind of addresses all of those
different needs it's a it's it's in a
recyclable pan we deliver it into a
refrigerator at a central point of
distribution whether that's at a school
whether that's in a corporate you know
office location whether that's in a
community center so you're picking it up
out of a refrigerator you're not getting
it delivered with a bunch of you know
insulation and ice packs and then it's a
and because of those things and because
we're building on our existing
infrastructure and we already have this
infrastructure in place of food
production and delivery we're able to
deliver it at a price point that really
works for the families that we are that
we are serving and we've stayed very
focused on making sure that that price
point stays accessible so you know
really understanding who your consumer
is when you're developing the product is
incredibly important spending time with
them I mean even though I am a mom I've
got you know three kids my husband and I
try to figure out how we're gonna make
dinner every day that doesn't mean that
we understand every consumer that we're
trying to work with so actually going
out and spending time in people's
kitchens testing out different different
kind of iterations of our product is was
incredibly enlightening to our entire
team as we as we went through this
really understanding you know we I think
we had a very good understanding of how
we were going to get the meals to these
points of distribution we hold it kind
of that last mile we have you know
trucks that are already going into
communities and into school sites but
how do we actually get people to walk
that last 10 feet to go and get the meal
so we spent a lot of time we're we're
still spending a lot of time really
testing different ways to get people to
actually you know go to those those last
10 feet to pick up the meal and then the
feedback and learning loop is ongoing so
every we've even though we feel like
we've got the product honed we've got
you know this incredible kind of menu of
items where you get a you get your kind
of dinner kit everything's already
chopped for you everything is marinated
the sauces are made everything goes it
goes into these recyclable pans that you
just put into your oven everything cooks
at 425 for 30 minutes it's very easy
we've taken a lot of that thinking and a
lot of that work out of it but you're
still putting raw food into the oven and
coming out with a fresh freshly cooked
meal you're not microwaving something or
just you know reheating something
so some we've kind of developed that
product to a certain extent and we're
getting great incredible feedback on it
but we're all we're still continuously
learning so somebody might say oh what
the green beans didn't cook all the way
at the time that you said so we went
back and we tested the green bean
cooking time again and we changed the
directions and you know if we've made
sure to keep the business very this this
kind of innovation group incredibly
nimble we're not over investing in
packaging or not over investing and you
know in a lot of things that are gonna
be hard to kind of turn around if we
need to pivot and do something
differently or you need to make a tweak
or a change so keeping that feedback and
learning loop ongoing even as we're kind
of even as we think certain things are
honed and complete you know we're really
continuing to to be very nimble and an
agile kind of as we're developing so the
future I think where we're gonna take
this is still to be determined where our
core business as I said is still growing
we're we're gonna be serving you know
even more schools and community sites
next year but now we're gonna have this
this other layer of what we can offer to
our schools and community sites so we're
not just going to be able to bring
healthy breakfast and lunch and after
school meals to students but we're gonna
have this offering for families that
will be you know available through the
the schools that we serve we're starting
here still you know as I said we're
still kind of in the learning loop and
worse we're just doing this right now in
the Bay Area we haven't expanded this
out to the out to the you know other
parts of the country that we're working
in but as soon as we have some of those
some of those key questions kind of
answered we'll be rolling it out to
other parts of the country and I think
there's you know we're still continuing
to kind of build and learn the platform
and the program as we go
but I think just for some key takeaways
and and where you can learn from this
and maybe as you're if you're starting a
business or you're you know trying to
trying to pivot your current business
into a different direction I'll try to
offer a couple of takeaways so one is
this there's this tension between you
want to isolate the new and isolate the
innovation so that it doesn't distract
from that 99% of the rest of your
business you want to make sure that
you've got you know a solid kind of
team and resources dedicated to the the
core business so you want to isolate it
but at the same time you want to you
want to kind of not separate it so much
that it that you start kind of moving
away from where your core competencies
are and that's that analogy of the train
you know if you're if you're building if
you're building a train and that's your
business and you're trying to build an
airplane on the side that's gonna be
totally different from what your what
your core business is so you know if we
were as we're as we were looking at this
we said well we already have fresh food
production we already have refrigerated
trucks on the road we have this very
unique access to this channel of you
know schools and community centers and
and and everything we do comes back to
are we leveraging those core assets are
we leveraging those core assets or are
we looking at building a whole different
a whole different kind of company and
when we keep coming back to you know
leverage the core assets make sure this
is something that we know how to do and
we're just kind of tweaking it around
the around the edges so it's that
tension between isolating your
innovation and keeping keeping of you
know keeping it from being distracting
but truly leveraging what your what your
core is and what your what you're truly
good at and at the end of the day I
think I can't stress this enough
especially in a food company but product
excellence has to be the number one
focus of every single effort every
single day and you know if if somebody
has a bad experience with a meal or a
food item it's really hard to get them
back and I think this is probably the
case with just about any with just about
any product so no matter if you're on
day one of your business or day you know
ten thousand and sixty four making sure
you're starting and finishing your day
focused on your product on the quality
of your product and how your product is
is kind of meeting your end users needs
is the most important place you can
spend your time thank you
[Applause]